bom dia uma responsável o negócio é
daquele aquele frio na barriga mas vamos
lá é pessoal a gente colocou como tema
desse papo inovar ou morrer é não foi
pra fazer drama na época e parece um
tema assim ficção científica ou de filme
a gente escolheu esse tema porque eu vou
falar de uma indústria que ela realmente
ou se reinventa no contexto nacional ela
está fadada a deixar de existir
é eu vou falar da indústria da
construção é nomeadamente da construção
de infraestrutura né pra quem não é da
área de engenharia civil engenharia
civil ela tem duas grandes vertentes né
a construção de infraestrutura que a
gente vai tá falando de barragens
hidrelétricas ferrovias rodovias etc ea
construção predial né que a gente está
falando de residências é fábricas
construções de menor porte é muito
interessante eu acho que todo mundo
quando olha pra mim eu trabalho no
mercado de infra a 12 anos e eu não
tenho muito a cara de quem trabalha no
mercado de infraestrutura porque a gente
sempre imagina o mercado
predominantemente masculino é
predominantemente as pessoas de cabeça
branca e aí você vê uma menina falando
de inovação aberta em construção é eu
acho que a minha missão aqui hoje
explicar para vocês porque a minha
história de vida faz sentido com essa
indústria
e como que eu acredito que a gente
deveria está redesenhando essa realidade
pra falar disso eu tenho que começar
falando um pouco de mim é eu aos cinco
anos de idade eu fui diagnosticada como
imperativa e eu não sei se vocês
conhecem crianças hiperativas mais a
criança hiperativa ela tem algumas
qualidades como por exemplo inteligência
mas eu tenho alguns problemas como
dificuldade de concentração dificuldades
de atenção e essa dificuldade esse
excesso de energia que eu tinha na minha
infância ele fez com que eu fosse
expulsa do meu primeiro colégio e eu
lembro de ser classificada como uma das
piores alunos do colégio justamente por
esse acesso de energia
é felizmente né depois que eu fui
expulsa dessa escola
meus pais me colocaram em outra escola
obrigatoriamente e nessa nova escola
tanto a minha professora quanto os meus
pais eles entenderam o problema que eles
tinham na mão e eles mudaram
completamente o approach para tratar
comigo em relação aos meus estudos
então eles acharam maneiras de
incentivar a gostar de estudar eu
participei dn olimpíadas de matemática
eles manipularam onde série eles acharam
formas de transformar aquilo
interessante pra mim
e dessa maneira eu me apaixonei por
estudar e esse me apaixonar por estudar
é uma coisa que me acompanhou minha vida
inteira
tanto que muito depois de eu ter uma
presença tão ativa dos meus pais no
estúdio nunca conseguir parar de estudar
por causa disso
essa mudança já pronto e ressignifica ou
toda a visão que eu tinha em relação à
educação
e eu acho que foi essa experiência que
fez eu perceber muito cedo a diferença
que faz você fazer as coisas de forma
diferente
o quanto que você busca maneiras
alternativas ou diferentes de resolver
um problema pode gerar resultados
completamente diferente também
eu continuei estudando e como eu vi toda
essa transformação acontecendo na minha
vida eu me apaixonei por transformação
eu escolhi engenharia civil porque eu
gostava muito de matemática e quem é de
exatas em geral gosta de ficar ali na
zona de conforto e eu também escolheu
engenharia civil porque dentro das
engenharias era engenharia que na minha
visão era mais transformacional é a que
mais tangível mente ouvir as coisas
saindo do chão e virando alguma coisa e
eu fui pra infraestrutura por isso
também porque dentro das vertentes de
engenharia civil era que mais gerava
obras nem muito grandes muito o que
causava impacto na vida das pessoas
muito grande também
então essa transformação que engenharia
civil gera foi o que me fez apaixonar
por ela
é só que eu não sei que quantos de vocês
já fizeram obra em casa
a obra uma coisa reconhecida por ser bem
organizada né
assim sempre acaba no prazo no custo não
é muito produtivo normalmente só que não
então
ou quando eu fui para a obra trabalhar
isso há 12 anos atrás eu percebi que não
era bonito e elegante como é na
faculdade
você não acha que esse modelo de
estrutura bonitinho organizado que você
consegue fazer tudo é muito bagunçado
na realidade se você olha indústria da
construção a produtividade dela não só é
muito baixo em relação à produtividade
da indústria
como é menor do que a dela mesma há 20
anos atrás é tem relatórios que colocam
a gente como a indústria - inovadora de
todas a gente já perdeu para a pesca em
inovação
então assim é a gente tem que entender
que a gente está falando de uma
indústria que é extremamente relevante
porque a infraestrutura é uma parte
significativa do pib de um país e que
mesmo assim é extremamente produtiva
e justamente por ela ser tão relevante
então improdutiva que a gente vê que as
publicações que a gente vê que as
publicações recentes todas essas
publicações são de 2016 a este an
elas mostram o super potencial
relacionado à inovação na construção
civil porque eu tô falando de um setor
que chega a ser 15 e 20 por cento do pib
de um país e que ele tem uma
produtividade muito baixa e o que essas
publicações todas trazem aqui essa
produtividade baixa ela pode mudar por
meio da inovação e ela pode mudar muito
por meio da inovação e voltando lá pra
minha história né
é assim que eu me formei eu fui morar em
manaus e eu fui trabalhar com construção
pesada em manaus durante quatro anos e
manaus é uma região é uma cidade que
pelo brasil
você só acessa por barco ou por avião em
uma cidade que a logística é muito
complexa
é uma cidade que tem disponibilidade de
mão de obra muito baixa quando vai falar
de engenharia conectada e é de se
esperar que as produtividades lá sejam
ainda piores do que a média histórica do
país
então é uma situação que é muito difícil
de você construir no meio da amazônia é
quando a gente foi construído em manaus
e de novo na itália
tiba que só cheguei lá todo empolgado e
com vontade de mudar as coisas de querer
fazer diferente
é a gente vai perceber que existiam sim
formas da gente melhorar a produtividade
nessas obras
e a gente começou a tentar fazer
inovação incremental fechado ali dentro
da empresa
a gente começou a tentar mudar algumas
práticas de construção ea gente vai
percebendo ganhos muito significativos
de produtividade principalmente por
industrialização dessa construção
eu falo de trabalhar com pré-moldados eu
falo de redesenhar processos
eu falo de criar fluxos de valor que
fazia mais sentido para as pessoas e
quando a gente foi percebendo que isso
na prática gerava eficiência foi dando
aquele gage eu consigo fazer sabe aquela
sensação de que você colocou na prática
alguma coisa diferente para rodar e você
me deu resultado e deu certo e isso vai
te empolgando e a gente foi ficando
empolgado fomos virando um núcleo de
pessoas que estava apaixonada por aquilo
e que percebiam que nessa indústria
tinha sim como usar a tecnologia para
fazer as coisas de maneira diferente e
quando a gente estava no nosso pico da
empolgação que a gente tava muito né
gente era um grupo de 30 a 40 pessoas
muito empolgados em redesenhar
engenharia e vêm engenharia de outra
maneira
a gente teve em 2015 o estouro da
operação lava jato é eu não sei se você
já se perguntaram como é passar uma
crise como a lava jato de dentro das
empresas é é uma situação que ela foi
sem precedentes no país
você é apaixonado por uma indústria ela
está numa crise imensa ea gente tem
várias formas de enxergar lava-jato
obviamente mas da forma que eu mais
gosto é a lava jato ser a maior
oportunidade que esse país já teve de
redesenhar engenharia e construção
porque uma coisa que era a empolgação de
poucas pessoas de fazer engenharia
diferente
de repente virou a necessidade de todo
mundo isso é muito legal
então é a gente foi percebendo que
aquilo que para a gente é um sonho que
era aproximar
a área do campo da realidade da
engenharia que a gente estuda nos livros
de repente não tinha outra opção pra
ninguém
por isso que a gente fala tanto de
inovar ou morrer uma crise desse porte
ela não dá abertura para você tem outra
opção a não ser mais eficiente não sei
fazer diferente a não ser fazer
engenharia direito
então é toda a crise é uma super
oportunidade se você souber enxergar a
crise como oportunidade ea lava jato foi
a maior oportunidade que esse país teve
de redesenhar seu setor de
infraestrutura
a gente brinca que esse tipo de situação
em que a morte é certa e você tem alguma
esperança de se salvar
não é que você tem que colocar todas as
suas fichas nessa esperança ele gera um
nível de engajamento motivação
completamente diferente
é muito difícil você inovar uma empresa
de sucesso é muito mais fácil você
inovar numa empresa que está morrendo
porque as pessoas se comprometem muito
mais fácil quando elas se sentem
ameaçadas
então é a crise tem que ser vista como
uma oportunidade por todos nós
ok faz sentido ficamos empolgados mas a
grande pergunta é como fazer isso porque
a gente está falando de um setor
extremamente tradicional
extremamente consolidado como eu e novo
no setor de engenharia e construção em
infraestrutura é o primeiro passo para a
gente fazer isso eu trabalho nesse setor
há um tempo eu trabalho com um projeto
de transformação de cultura e inovação
há oito anos dentro de si
nesse setor a primeira coisa que a gente
percebeu aqui antropologia e tecnologia
têm que andar juntas
a gente entende que o comportamento
humano gera demandas tecnológicas e o
desenvolvimento da tecnologia muda o
comportamento das pessoas
muita gente foca em programas de
inovação corporativos pensando no lado
tecnológico desses programas porque é
mais fácil mais simples e mais tangível
pouca gente entende que em grandes
corporações
eu tô falando muito mais de gestão da
mudança do que de tecnologia a
tecnologia é um meio ela não é o fim
o fim
a propósito do que você está percorrendo
do que você está buscando no nosso caso
a gente começou então a estudar muito
como mudar o comportamento das pessoas
porque não adiantaria nada a gente
trazer tecnologia pra dentro da
construção se as pessoas não conseguiram
utilizar aquela tecnologia
o grande problema da inovação não é a
geração de idéias é a implantação dessas
idéias ea transformar e transformar esse
resultado
então a gente começou a buscar estudos
que falassem disso a gente encontrou o
estudo é da máquina chamado influência e
ao papel que é um estudo que fala que o
comportamento humano ele muda baseado em
quatro alavancas
eles estudaram 27.000 transformações
organizacionais e as quatro avançam
fazer sentido para as pessoas então você
tem uma comunicação que ela consiga
mostrar a necessidade de mudança o que
no caso de uma crise dessa fazia todo o
sentido a segunda alavanca alavancas
treinamento eu não posso perguntar para
as pessoas a pedir às pessoas que
trabalham de maneira diferente se eu não
a suporto para fazer isso
a terceira lawan que alavanca de exemplo
da liderança que ele chama de um módulo
o quanto os meus líderes são exemplos
vivos vivos daquilo que eles pedem que
as pessoas façam ea última lawan
alavancas mecanismos afirmativos o
quanto os meus sistemas internos e
fomenta os comportamentos que a empresa
diz que ela gostaria que fossem
implementados ao longo desses oito anos
que eu trabalhei com gestão da mudança e
transformação de cultura
eu percebi que você fazer com que as
corporações entendam o quão profundo é
inovar não é só eu tenho uma área
prende-se de inovação eu entender que
inovação é cultura é como eu consigo
fazer com que as minhas pessoas possam
errar possam experimentar possam
aprender e tirar aquela síndrome do
herói serem mais colaborativas trazerem
idéias de fora como o inov de maneira
aberta como eu consigo fazer com que
idéias que são melhores do que as minhas
que existem fora daqui
venham pra dentro das organizações eu
costumo brincar que as organizações são
transatlânticos e que para você virar um
transatlântico demora ele é pesado é
parrudo é difícil e por isso você tem
que virar com uma análise de risco
porque se você virar para o lado errado
você afunda
e é por isso que você faz inovação de
maneira aberta também são formas de você
testa a água seja por instituições sejam
os seus clientes fazer pilotos sejam
quase startup são maneiras de você
conseguir transformar isso entendendo e
aprendendo o que está acontecendo ao
longo do tempo
é nesses oito anos eu acompanhei mais de
4000 ou shoppings de geração de idéias
para a construção civil é eu ajudei no
lançamento da primeira acelerador de
construtech do brasil e hoje nós temos
aí quatro ou cinco aceleradora de
construtech existentes graças existentes
graças a deus a gente teve que tomar
decisões muito difíceis do tipo pessoas
que têm muito no raul e deram muito
resultado no passado mas que são
incapazes de mudar a gente tem que
deixar essas pessoas partirem das
organizações que a gente precisa de uma
em sete diferentes e isso também é uma
decisão muito difícil de fazer e se a
gente está falando de inovação de
verdade isso é necessário e quando a
gente fala de engenharia complexa
muita gente fala assim por xuxa é tira
todo mundo e traz gente nova
o problema é que você não acha por aí
disponível um cara que sabe calcular uma
barragem trabalhou no google essa pessoa
não existe então você não consegue você
tem que pegar aquele cara que sabe
calcular barragem e torná lo mais
inovador porque você tem que casar as
duas coisas
ao longo desses néons 11 12 anos aí que
eu trabalho com construção e dos oito
anos que eu trabalho só com o projeto de
transformação uma coisa ficou muito
claro pra mim é possível sim inovar
nesse mercado
a gente já chegou a quadruplicar as
nossas produtividade algum serviço e não
existe uma realidade diferente uma
realidade em que a construção civil
desempenho o papel que ela precisa de se
empenhar nesse país sem inovação
inovação aberta transparente que envolva
cliente/fornecedor status instituições
de ensino
se isso não for uma verdade pra gente a
gente nunca vai mudar essa situação
e no fim das contas o que a gente quer
né eu falo isso muito é muito fácil a
gente se abster do problema a gente fala
assim por xuxa
essa indústria está queimadas indústria
cheio de problema não vou mexer com isso
com o país a gente não pode se dar ao
luxo de abrir mão de infraestrutura
porque a infraestrutura é muito
relevante para o nosso país e não vai
mudar de maneira mágica só vai mudar se
tiver gente boa que está disposta a
entrar nessa indústria mudar essa
realidade ea gente que tem que fazer
isso então a gente precisa entender que
a responsabilidade sim de todos nós
fazer com que isso volte a se
desenvolver volte a crescer e que a
gente apaga essa página do passado e
faça as coisas de maneira diferente de
fato porque se essa indústria morre como
eu falei inovar ou morrer ela morre pra
todo mundo e é um problema de todo mundo
isso é ruim pra todo mundo e eu
pessoalmente sei que se a gente tem um
approach diferente
as coisas são muito diferentes se a
gente tiver a construção apronte
diferente assim como meus pais tiveram
pra mim em relação ao ensino
a gente vai ter um resultado muito
diferente porque isso não vale só para
mudar a vida das pessoas
isso vale para mudar a vida das
organizações também no fim das contas o
que a gente quer é o que a
infraestrutura faz de melhor
é desenvolvimento econômico é
desenvolvimento humano é crescimento
desse país e isso passa por
infraestrutura porque é uma área muito
relevante
então a gente não pode simplesmente
continuar ignorando ela ou só apontando
o dedo a gente precisa fazer alguma
coisa e essa alguma coisa passa
necessariamente por inovação
obrigada
[Aplausos]